oh my god Rob core ok so check us out
this story is called the brave and the
mold like if that gives you any
indication of what it's about and I
swear to god this story is hilarious
it's like the best thing coming out of
DC rebirth right now like it's
absolutely one of my favorite stories
with Batman now here's the funny thing
this has Swamp Thing and like I've never
read Swamp Thing
I'm a little ashamed to admit it I have
never read Swamp Thing once in my life
like I've never read a single comic of
hissed
I heard that like the new 52 Swamp Thing
is really really good but I've never
read it before and it's kind of weird
because he's like a pop culture mainstay
right like most everybody knows what's
going on like like who's Swamp Thing is
when they see him but I kind of a read
anything about him this is like my first
real exposure in comics to his character
and it's amazing so here's the years ago
thing so initially this picks up I mean
technically it's kind of like chapter 2
they kind of split the chapters like the
old anthology books from the 1940s and
50s and 60s where you would have like a
singular book that would go on for 30
pages but you would have like Part 1
which would be like four pages apart -
might be six pages or chapter one
chapter to sell on those lines but all
that really happens here is just like
some guy in an apartment is shot in the
head and he's kind of singing this
really haunting song this is actually
picked up on by by Jim Gordon and Batman
now this is where things get hilarious
because with the character of swamp The
Swamp Thing from what I've read and for
what I understand he's tied into
something called the green and that I'm
pretty familiar with just because of the
whole lot in Justice stories but the way
it works as far as I'm aware the wait
originally worked it's one thing was
just kind of like this outlier in DC
Comics he was just kind of out there in
no-man's land like Hellblazer in the
vertigo stories he was just kind of out
there by himself and he really wasn't
tied in to like the rest of DC but with
the new 52 DC roll him into the shared
universe what they did is they came up
with an idea called the green and what
they basically said was that in the
realm of DC's landscape you've got the
green which is plant lies you've got the
red which is animals you've got the
black which is rot it was almost kind of
like this earth-based equivalent to like
the emotional spectrum from the Green
Lantern mythos but the fact remains that
Swamp Thing is tied to the green much
like poison ivy and so what this means
is that he is effectively immortal I
mean as long as plant life exists he
will exist and he can literally just
kind of like reconstitute himself take
on additional mass he
has strength of a level that's never
been calculated before is incredibly
capable in terms of what it is that he
can do but that's about the extent of my
knowledge on his character after reading
the story I'm almost inclined to go back
and read the new 52 Swamp Thing just to
see if it was really that good I have no
idea how long it went on for it I can't
imagine it went on too long
52 issues is what everything ran for in
the new 52 because they were all Monthly
titles so it's not like it was a super
lengthy thing but but a doctor names
here the Swamp Thing basically just kind
of reconstitutes himself or you know
forms out of some flat matter and just
kind of makes his presence known to Jim
Gordon that this is a funny thing
because that man knows who's Swamp Thing
is right so that man's just kind of like
looking at the crime scene and analyzing
things and Jim Gordon is just like okay
like this giant swamp monster just kind
of emerged behind us and I really feel
like that needs to be said right now
like I really feel like if we have to
acknowledge that this happened and it's
just funny to see people reacting to
this and that's one of the things I love
about about Kings writing is because he
gives the characters so much character
like Jim Gordon is just this guy just
like okay I mean I guess it was only a
matter of time before something like
this happened we live in a world where
bullets bounce off of a man because he's
an alien we've got a guy who flies
around at night or just like glides
around at night dressed as a bat beating
people up it makes sense that there
would be a giant guy who's composed of
you know plant matter appearing in the
middle of a room and a crime scene but
it's kind of cool because while this is
happening Batman's just like is there a
problem
you just he's totally responding to
something as if he's a normal person not
from here we switch over to Alfred and
this again is another funny scenario
because Swamp Thing being being composed
you know of compost you know being a
giant compost heap it's just kind of
like leaving marks and stuff on the
ground leaving plant marks on the ground
you know Alfred cleans this kind of
stuff up but it's just like yeah it's
all par for the course when your outfit
it's just kind of the way it goes you
know messes get brought in by the giving
tree' things just come in messes get
made and that's really it but again it's
one of these kind of cool things now the
interesting thing about this is that Tom
King is so good at characters and this
is what a story really kind of starts to
shift a bit towards the character
development and the reason why is
because with Swamp Thing there is no
such thing as depth at least as far as
he explains it here to Bruce Wayne there
is no such thing as death a person that
comes from the earth so they come
from life revolutionaries you want to
look at it they come from divine
intervention they die so to speak but
they become one with the earth and in
turn they feed plants and they feed
trees which provide life-giving oxygen
or nourishment to different you know
critters and organisms across the world
and so there's always kind of like this
cycle of life and death so to speak but
no one's ever really dead and that's
what makes us so cool is because in his
mind he basically says look you know
this man who was killed is my father he
sent me letters if you tried to talk to
me I spoke to him maybe once after the
whole instance with the swamp where I
became something and that was really it
like this guy never really had a role in
the life of Alec Halden instead he was
just kind of disguised and Alec knew
about but never really did anything with
now the reason why this matters and the
reason why this is so cool it's because
what it does is it bridges the gap
between Bruce Wayne and Swamp Thing
Swamp Thing is this guy where he's
basically like I have this man who's my
father but I'll never be able to talk to
anymore I'll never be able to like
converse with I'll never be able to
learn more about him not that I ever did
know much about him in the first place
but now that I want to know about him I
can't because he's effectively gone I'll
never be able to speak to him and the
conventional sense you know with Bruce
Wayne it's much the same way his mother
and father were killed in front of them
he'll never be able to talk to Thomas
Wayne he'll never be able to talk to
Martha Wayne he'll never be able to get
their opinions get their ideas ask them
do I make you proud that's one of the
most significant moments about the
button that's why the encounter between
Thomas Wayne from the flashpoint
universe and Bruce Wayne from the main
DC Universe was so significant because
even if it's not his biological father
into in the traditional sense it's still
his father you know it's still the
Thomas Wayne that he knew albeit just a
different version of Thomas Wayne and it
was emotional and it was visceral and it
was amazing and so because of that it
creates some real emotional tie to these
characters if that kind of makes any
sense and so ultimately what is up
happening here is it's one thing
basically says look I'm just kind of
here because I'm interested in solving
this murder that really kind of seems to
be it I mean it's like look my dad was
killed I want to know what's going on
now the initial indication here from
Bruce Wayne is that this man was
murdered on like the 84th floor of a
building and there's only a handful of
people who could have been the ones
responsible for that now the first one
he goes after his kite man and kite man
through kite man is amazing the kite man
so cool all this guy does is fly around
and yell kite man
oh yeah that's all he does like that's
his thing that's the whole ordeal now of
course the cool thing about this is that
Tom King very much plays on the idea of
like what Batman's about right like we
know as the Batman is the guy who
doesn't kill but the bad guys don't need
to know that the bad guys just need to
believe they're gonna die and if your
kite man and your your your soaring 500
feet above the ground and Batman latches
on to you and will not let you go the
only thing racing through your mind is
you're going to smash into the ground
and Batman's gonna let you die he's
going to bail out you know a second
before it happens he's gonna live but
kite man's gonna be done with all his
living it was kind of cool because I
mean we know this is not going to happen
we know he's not going to die but the
questions that Batman has is you know
who is it that committed this crime or
how would they have gained access to the
resources necessary to commit this crime
because kite man didn't invent his own
stuff he got his stuff from somewhere
else so again it's really kind of like
one of these whodunit mystery sort of
things and so what can man basically
says is that he grabbed his stuff from a
guy named Mooney money now of course
Mooney money is clearly a comic book
stand in for Guy Fieri but the fact
remains here that going through all
these different sources and jumping
through all these different guys
eventually Batman you know basically
realizes that this murder seems to have
been done by a guy by the name of
headhunter now headhunters the guy that
I know nothing about I don't know if
he's new I don't know if he is a
character that was recently created I
really don't like using Wikipedia's just
because anybody can edit them but I
don't know anything about that guy but
really the only explanation we need is
what's offered here where he's basically
just like a mercenary and he always
executes his victims by shooting him
twice in the head and no one knows why
he shoots the second time but the funny
thing about this is that Bruce Wayne
kind of hinted this and says look this
guy is going to be hard to find because
he basically commits his crimes
he goes underground he goes on the run
and then he only resurfaces whenever
he's ready to commit another murder and
so the guy is sporadic I mean he pops up
here he pops up there but there's no
pattern to what it is that he does
outside of the murders that he commits
and so it's really kind of a cool
scenario because what this shows us is
that even within the realm of Gotham
City or even the world as a whole there
are some people out there who were just
that good at evading Batman they're just
that good at evading him and again it
makes Bruce Wayne more realistic it
makes them more grounded and makes them
more tangible and basically telling us
that despite all of his vaunted
resources all of his wealth all of his
capabilities at the end of the day he is
still only human and he can only do what
a normal
even can do and so because of this
swampthing basically chimes in and says
he's currently entering the Gotham
Museum of Art and when Batman's like how
did you find that out
Swamp things response is that the grass
told him and that's the coolest thing
about this because that man's like
alright look man the grass art if you're
talking to the grass that's cool
whatever man do what you do then you be
you I'll be me and we'll call it a day
and so it's just really kind of funny to
see these interactions between these
characters who would normally never meet
because they're so starkly different
right I mean Batman is hanging out with
plant matter as they're going to
investigate a murder and so again it's
interesting to kind of see how these
characters relate to one another how
they deal with one another now of course
once they get to the Gotham Museum they
immediately encounter head hunter and
head hunter really just kind of starts
talking about how he had killed this guy
he had killed a father of Swamp Thing
just because of the fact that he was
sort of bragging about how he knows
heroes or he hasn't in with superheroes
so to speak only insofar that he knew
his son was Swamp Thing and that was
really about it but it was one of these
scenarios where it was this situation
where a guy was basically spouting off
of the mouth in the wrong place at the
wrong time and headhunter effectively
killed him you know basically killed him
for that purpose now in response to this
Swamp Thing immediately kills headhunter
like he just immediately crushes him you
know actually back that's kind of
begging him to stop the whole time but
as soon as he's done
you know Swamp Thing starts crying and
basically talking about how his father's
dad he's never going to be able to talk
to his father again
Batman's immediate response is like what
happened to like there is no death what
happened to like everything lives on you
know to like life descending and all
that stuff like what happened to that
it's not things like now then he's just
dead that's basically what it is and
Batman's so pissed like that man reason
the ride Ikey is so pissed off because
in the mind of that man Swamp Thing used
them right like Swamp Thing shows up
with this whole dog-and-pony show up oh
well you know nothing's are really dead
everything just kind of lives on no a
plant life and different things like
that you know but it's basically him
just kind of turned coding here just
being like that's it man everything's
dead fielders there's that's good
there's nothing to a man like you die
and then that's it like that's just the
end of you you know and it's kind of
crazy because while Batman's reading him
the riot act Swamp Thing is like I gotta
go and he basically just bails out and
that's it and it really just kind of
ends with them screaming at him that's
pretty much all there is to it it is an
amazing story this is so good
it is the perfect ending to a Batman
story
and I really hope this question goes out
to you guys who are Swamp Thing fans my
question is this is the new 52 Swamp
Thing like this or is it just like kind
of weird and dark and so on because this
is an amazing story and I absolutely
love this I love seeing Batman reading
swampthing the ride I figured like Swamp
Thing could crush him like a bug right
like something would be like you know
what I'm tired to be Batman and then
that's just the end of Bruce length it'd
be so cool like it's just a cool
scenario to see Batman just not caring
and just screaming at Swamp Thing and
The Swamp Thing just being like I'm out
peace and just bailing is it's just kind
of a funny funny scenario but anyway
guys I thought this was like a really
cool one-off story just kind of a you
know a one-shot thought that was pretty
interesting but if you guys are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
[Music]